- [Bob Kendrick:] We're talking
about some of the
greatest baseball players
to ever put on a baseball uniform.
- During the late 1800s,
during the time of Civil War,
we knew that Major League
Baseball was a sport
that was really building their foundation.
We just finally formed
the U.S colored troops.
And when they were in camp,
what were they doing for entertainment?
Getting the wood, a rock,
and they would play baseball.
- Here we are fighting in a Civil War,
and yet could not play what
was America's national pastime.
- During the late 1800s,
they didn't actually have Black leagues.
What they had is like regional teams.
So there was Black
baseball being played right
along with everybody else.
Right from the beginning,
there was a color line.
And part of the reason
there was a color line is
because the Black teams
were so outstanding
that they knew that they would be defeated
if they brought them into the league.
So they immediately banned those teams.
Essentially, they began to
play their game in isolation.
- When we go back
and look at the early
era of Black baseball,
it was pretty haphazard.
You had several folks of dark
skin who had made their way
into what we now know as
Major League Baseball.
Moses Fleetwood Walker was,
as we kind of recognize, the
first known Black player to
play on what would be
considered a major league team.
Fleetwood Walker was
a bare-handed catcher.
- Tony Mullane,
who was a white pitcher,
didn't want to receive signs
from Moses Fleetwood Walker.
So Fleetwood Walker caught all year,
not knowing when a curveball was coming.
- And it didn't last very long before guys
like Adrian "Cap" Anson
formed what we call quote, unquote,
"a gentleman's agreement"
that ultimately banned Blacks
from playing on white major league teams.
And that agreement would stay
in place for the next six decades.
- In 1887, there was an
attempt to form a major league
of Black baseball.
It didn't really have the
organization and the finances.
I think they played 13 games
and then they were done.
- But the movement was there.
The concept was there.
The idea was there that
people would support
an organization like this.
- The "History of Colored Base Ball"
by Sol White was very instrumental
in covering a period of
baseball that we have no way
of knowing more about because those people
from the early 1900s
have long been deceased.
The book was groundbreaking
in that it introduced ballplayers
that we never heard of.
From his book, we learned about Pete Hill,
who's in the Hall of Fame.
Emmett Bowman.
So many great ballplayers
that we didn't know
about are documented.
- This is the first
Black man who's actually
chronicling the history of
African American baseball.
Baseball was truly Black America's game
in that early part of the century.
- Everyone talks about that
Blacks couldn't play in the major leagues.
But what folks don't recognize is
that African American teams would play
against barnstorming teams
from the major leagues,
from the minor leagues.
So Blacks and whites
played against each other
before Jackie Robinson
integrated baseball.
- If we really want to
get honest about it,
they knew these guys could play.
But because of society and America,
they couldn't find a place for them
because the racism was more important
than the national game.
- In that book,
one chapter was written
by Andrew "Rube" Foster.
- You can't tell the
story of the Negro league
without starting with the man,
Andrew "Rube" Foster, the father-
- The father of Black baseball.
- Whether we're talking Black
baseball, white baseball
blue, green, red, yellow,
is the greatest baseball mind
this sport has ever seen.
- Rube Foster played the game.
- Rube was a dominant yet dynamic pitcher.
- He is credited with having invented
what we now know to be the screwball.
- It is recorded that he won
44 straight games in a season.
Just imagine that compared
to today's pitcher.
He actually got his nickname
Rube from an exhibition game.
He went up against Hall
of Famer Rube Waddell,
and he actually beat him.
So his teammates started calling him Rube,
and that nickname stuck with him.
- Rube Foster became a manager.
1907, he became manager of
the Chicago Leland Giants.
His team was one of the
greatest teams in America.
Rube Foster became an owner.
- He literally went to
owner Frank Leland and said,
"I want you to give up all
of your controlling rights."
Mr. Leland refused, as you
would think any owner would.
But Rube at that point in time just said,
"OK, then I quit."
And that's what he did; he quit.
He took Mr. Leland to court
for the naming rights
of the Leland Giants,
and he ultimately won.
Rube developed
and created his own team
as the Leland Giants.
And that's how he became
owner of the team.
- Around 1919, Rube Foster
started to travel around
and meet with different owners
of teams in the major cities.
And so they came together
in the Paseo YMCA, and they realized
that, "OK, we can pull
this off in the West."
- There were some efforts
to create a Negro league,
but they had failed.
We didn't get that real
magic formula until 1920,
when Rube Foster forms
the Negro National League.